if you're handing over your computer to
a stranger there's nothing you care more
about than your privacy so for computer
repair shops like los angeles-based
cyberguy earning customers trust is a
huge struggle we are saying them we're
not gonna looking at the files and
folders or private files but they don't
trust the reason is that most of us have
things on our computer that we don't
want seen as someone with a recurring
medical issue
I keep photos on my laptop that are
meant only for my doctor's eyes and when
my computer breaks down I can never be
certain that a repair technician won't
be tempted to snoop but fortunately for
cyberguy owner herman acneic i had a
solution your biggest problem is no
matter how much you tell your customers
you're not going to look at their nude
or sexy pics they'll always be skeptical
because you're a sexual being right okay
so whatever desire I have it's not gonna
be affecting my business what do you
mean okay if you don't eat food
you're hungry always okay mm-hmm if you
eat food you're gonna be full you don't
feel any more your hunger right so if
you don't pleasure yourself at home
maybe you're gonna feel it at the office
or while walking on the street you can
feel those desires in a way so you're
saying you pleasure yourself so much at
home that it doesn't affect you at work
correct
despite Herrmann's claim that he gets
everything out of his system before
arriving at work each morning his
customers will never completely trust
him because he's a sexual being
but if herman recruited repair
technicians from the one percent of
Americans who identify as asexual
meaning they have no sexual desires
whatsoever customers could finally feel
confident about getting their computers
repaired without the staff being tempted
to look at their private
photos the plan put customers at ease by
offering the world's first asexual
computer repair as when they see any
image nude image so they're not gonna be
desired or effecting in theory yes
theory I see
neither Herman nor I knew much about
asexuality but he was willing to give it
a shot so I went to the Internet's most
popular asexuality forum and posted a
job notification to see if anyone would
fit the criteria that Herman would need
and later that week I set up interviews
with everyone who responded you know
just the lack of feeling a sexual
attraction and need for sex is all that
asexuality truly is and there's a
spectrum to it too so if you're not
thinking about sex what are you thinking
about well it always depends I mean I
suppose most of the time I'm actually
thinking about superheroes my favorite
of which being Aquaman hence the orange
shirt so when most people are thinking
of sex you're thinking of Aquaman well
that's a funny way of putting it but I
suppose though after learning more about
the asexual lifestyle I was feeling
optimistic that this could work
so right now sitting across from me you
feel no sexual attraction no you're
another person to me well I was born an
asexual and I assume that I shall still
be an asexual upon leaving this world so
after a rigorous vetting process using a
heart rate monitor to judge their
physical response to a series of
stimulating images I found in a stock
photo database do you find this sexually
arousing or no
no no I offered the job to the two who
showed no spike in heart rate no matter
how stimulating the image was so the
next day I brought the new recruits to
cyberguy to introduce them to Hermann so
this is Nicky and Randy and they're
asexual which okay they don't have a
desire to look at any customers private
nudes or sexy photos or you know they
just don't have those urges not so a
sense of privacy I mean yeah definitely
important to everybody they sexuality
right but someone like Herman might yeah
tempted yeah possibility right yeah but
you wouldn't know be tempted ever no no
no right so that's why their lack of
arousal was perfect but they still
weren't computer experts I removed
viruses from computers before but with
instructions so knowing they would need
Herman's clothes guidance when doing a
repair I installed a series of walls in
the back of the store to create a
quarantine viewing booth for Herman so
the repair area would remain free of
sexual contamination the only access
point into the inner chamber was through
a military-grade keycode block that only
D asexuals would have the code to so
after putting up a brand new banner out
front and giving the repair staff their
code to enter the desexualized zone the
code is
for okay so don't tell Herman okay
they securely sealed themselves inside
the repair area while me and Herman
waited for customer is up front
you didn't see the code no I didn't do
you promise I promise
okay
before long the first customer arrived
it's like very slow and certainly gets
an internet sometimes so it was time to
see if he'd be impressed by the new
service so I don't know if you saw a
sign but we're the only computer repair
shop in town that offers a fully asexual
repair service okay are you familiar
with asexuals oh no I'm not okay
so the entire time your computer is here
no one with any sexual desires will be
touching it and that is the cyber guy
guarantee right yes
for sure 100% guarantee that full
disclosure Herman is a sexual person but
he will not be touching your computer at
any point what does that mean he's a
sexual person
yeah that's means so a sexual person as
me so we haven't some desires for
looking at the picture begin looking at
inside so we are curious about what is
inside what's contained inside it's a
nude photos video stuff so he has those
desires other people don't they don't
all the people that will be repairing it
the first customer was excited by the
concept
so now an asexual is coming up yes
[Music]